pour refonder l'europe et pour rétablir
la france
chers amis nous vivons une période de
crise avec le sentiment inquiétant de ne
plus pouvoir agir
nous perdons du terrain dans la
compétition économique et technologique
notre défense est le forces de sécurité
sont durement éprouvés par la menace
terroriste
[Musique]
une immigration non maîtrisée
déstabilise notre société
dans cette crise déconstruire le projet
européen serait une folie mais il serait
tout aussi absurde de poursuivre dans la
voie d'une europe qui ne marche pas
notre projet c'est le construire
l'europe qui pourra nous renforcer pour
ne plus subir notre avenir
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui les font enfin nos entreprises et
nos emplois en assumant une préférence
européenne et nationale qui protège
notre environnement par une barrière
écologique
pour imposer les mêmes règles à ce qui
importe chez nous car nos propres
producteurs et à nos agriculteurs qui
met fin aux élargissements et qui défend
nos frontières
face au défi migratoire l'europe que
nous voulons c'est celle qui respecte
les citoyens
qui renonce à l'excès de normes et de
contrôle pour nos artisans nos
commerçants nos entreprises
celle qui lui au contraire avec les
grands projets sur l'industrie la
défense les transports ou la santé
celle qui fédérera le laboratoire de
recherche pour guérir la maladie
d'alzheimer
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui redécouvre de calais d'abord une
civilisation un élan magnifique
l'histoire de nos racines
il faut nommer et transmettre
si nous voulons éviter le
communautarisme qui fracturent nos
sociétés il faut assumer ce lien qui
nous unit
[Musique]
si nous voulons arrêter de céder du
terrain à l'islamisme l'europe doit
définir une charte des devoirs qu'il
faudra respecter pour s'y établir
quand on vous demande quelle europe
voulez vous répondez nous voulons
l'europe de la civilisation et de
l'identité
c'est cette europe pour laquelle nous
nous engagions
nous sommes les seuls à défendre ce
projet solide clair et cohérent dans
quelques jours vous aurez dans vos mains
un choix décisif pour refonder l'europe
et pour rétablir la france